A giant, monstrous, crab-like claw closes
around the throat of an unimaginably huge
eel-like beast.
The beast’s terrible, writhing tentacles
wrap around and latch onto the immense crustacean,
and then the high-intensity beams of gamma
radiation start flying.
All the while, legions of skinless centaurs
swim in the waters around them, relishing
the violence.
And in the middle, a lone boat, the SCPS Mither,
manned by a team of Mobile Task Force operatives,
does all it can just to survive.
There are those who consider outer space to
be the ultimate achievement in exploration,
the one place that explorers have yet to chart
and understand.
However, some of the murkiest mysteries in
the universe are on our own planet, deep down
at the bottom of the ocean.
Ninety-five percent of the deep ocean remains
completely unexplored, and the little glimpses
we have gotten paint a picture of something
truly alien.
Giant squids, organisms that can breathe nitrogen,
luminescent predatory fish, and sharks as
old as the earth itself.
Even the SCP Foundation is still struggling
to fully grasp the depths of the ocean and
the strange beings that dwell there.
One of the most unusual aquatic findings in
the history of the Foundation is that of SCP-3700.
SCP-3700 refers to a circular area in the
North Sea with a diameter of 800 km.
The waters there are abnormally deep for the
region, with the sea floor resting at 5 km
beneath the ocean's surface.
There are two entities present in the waters
of SCP-3700, designated SCP-3700-1 and SCP-3700-2.
Interactions between these two entities are
responsible for anomalous changes to the meteorological
and geological conditions in the area.
SCP-3700-1 and SCP-3700-2 always interact
on the Spring and Fall equinoxes of any given
year, but they will also engage one another
throughout the year, seemingly at random.
But what, exactly, are SCP-3700-1 and 3700-2?
Aside from terrifying creatures of the deep.
SCP-3700-1 is an arthropod bearing an aesthetic
resemblance to the European lobster, only
much, much bigger, measuring six km in length.
The creature is green, with a mix of blue,
yellow, pink, and red markings across the
top of its exoskeleton that bear the appearance
of a woman's face.
It has six prehensile limbs, four of which
terminate in claws, and eight legs.
The entity's four eyes are compound and orange,
attached to stalks.
Anyone who gets close enough to observe the
creature's carapace in detail will notice
scars, cracks, and small holes, indicating
years and years of damage.
SCP-3700-1 has several anomalous qualities
in addition to its size.
In a fight, it is able to strike with its
appendages and produce cavitation bubbles
with a force greater than several tons of
dynamite.
Two of the entity's eyes are capable of blasting
concentrated gamma radiation at a chosen target.
The creature has the ability to impact the
weather around it, dispersing storms that
impede its ability to move with ease, and
can reach speeds of up to 100 km/hour.
In spite of its immense power, SCP-3700-1
is not aggressive and tends to ignore beings
in its vicinity other than SCP-3700-2.
Speaking of SCP-3700-2, it is a 32 km long
entity resembling a pelican eel in all aspects
except for its massive size, and the 13 appendages
that encircle the middle section of its body.
These appendages, which tuck inside its body
when not in use, are similar to the tentacles
of an octopus, complete with suckers.
The majority of the entity's body consists
of a sinewy tail, terminating in a sharp point.
When its mouth is open, it is an estimated
3 km deep.
Its flesh is black, and it has white, purple,
and red bioluminescent lines in the shape
of a man's face on either side of its torso.
SCP-3700-2's anomalous properties include
the ability to invoke storms with the severity
of category 5 hurricanes,and the ability to
produce whirlpools that draw in any vessel
within 150m so that it can rip them apart.
It is also able to produce high-energy soundwaves
as well as blue fire, which it emits from
its esophagus.
When the two entities interact, it results
in an epic struggle as each being attempts
to destroy or subdue the other.
When one is victorious, immediate changes
to the area follow.
When SCP-3700-1 wins, the storms and harsh
weather in the area will immediately calm,
and an era of fertility and abundance will
begin.
The reproductive rates of fauna in the ocean
and on the islands nearby increase threefold,
and the crop yield doubles.
The ocean itself becomes increasingly active,
and the erosion rates of the archipelago's
shores increase fivefold.
When SCP-3700-2 wins, however, the weather
conditions become dangerous, with raging hurricanes,
rapidly fluctuating temperatures, and constantly
changing storm fronts that cause destruction
of buildings and loss of life.
Naturally, this renders any ocean travel in
the area extremely difficult or even impossible.
Aquatic food sources are driven away by harsh
conditions, and livestock are killed by exposure
and disease.
Crops are unable to thrive in the high winds,
waterlogged soil, and lack of sunlight.
All the while, SCP-3700-2 swims throughout
the area, preying on unsuspecting ships and
menacing the coastline until SCP-3700-1 manifests
to challenge it again.
SCP-3700-2 will also regurgitate instances
of SCP-3456, though how or why this is possible
is unknown.
For those unfamiliar with SCP-3456, they are
a group of hairless, three-toed horse-like
creatures with thick, translucent skin and
human torsos fused to their backs.
They are most frequently seen near sites of
war, terrorist attacks, and devastating natural
disasters.
Direct observation of one of these entities
will draw their attention to the observer,
who the entity will then stalk and capture
before disappearing.
Due to their enormous size and ability to
anomalously manifest in their home waters,
SCP-3700-1 and 2 cannot be contained at a
Foundation site.
Instead, their containment is handled by Foundation
Naval Task Force Delta-7, "Northern Storm,"
who patrol the area in a combination of refurbished
battleships, destroyers, cruisers, and support
craft.
Additionally, measures have been taken to
suppress information about SCP-3700 among
the general population.
Details about the unusual depth of the waters
there have been stricken from public texts
and scientific publications.
SCP-3700-1 has been implanted with Donovan
holoprojectors, which disguise it as a pod
of humpback whales.
If SCP-3700-1 encounters SCP-3700-2, Delta-7
may engage Protocol "Winter Maelstrom."
This consists of destroyers deploying harpoon-based
anchors into SCP-3700-2's head, to hold it
in one location.
Next, the vessels work together to target
the entity until SCP-3700-1 is able to subdue
it.
If this does not prove effective, and SCP-3700-2
cannot be contained, then the task force will
implement Protocol Tumult.
At this point, naval and civilian crafts in
the area must be evacuated.
Trade and ferry routes to the archipelagos
must be rerouted for at least six months.
There will be constant aerial and naval engagement
with SCP-3700-2, and constant monitoring for
the reappearance of SCP-3700-1.
The behavior of SCP-3700-1 and SCP-3700-2
is largely very predictable, with one notable
exception.
On March 20, 2017, a pair of SCP Foundation-owned
battleships known as the Mither and the Teran
arrived at a point between the Orkney, Shetland,
and Faroe Archipelagos in the North Sea.
They were accompanied by the usual fleet of
Delta-7 ships.
Approximately 600 meters away from the ships'
anchor points, the water began to emit intense,
bright rays of light for a duration of three
minutes.
At this point, SCP-3700-1 appeared, visible
through the surface of the water.
Delta-7 withdrew their anchors, speeding toward
the entity.
As the ships caught up to the entity, it raised
two of its claws into the air, clicking them
together in a friendly greeting.
The Delta-7 ships followed the entity along
its usual swimming path for 30 minutes, and
during this time, all was peaceful.
But this peace didn't endure for long.
The tide began to change, literally, as large
black wall clouds formed overhead, the winds
picked up, and the waves churned violently.
In response, SCP-3700-1 raised its claws overhead,
waving them in a circular motion and parting
the clouds above it and Delta-7.
But this effort took a lot out of the creature,
and after thirty seconds, its antenna began
to droop, and it lowered its claws.
Still, the hole in the clouds remained, allowing
a spot of sunshine to break through and beam
down on the Foundation vessels.
600 meters ahead, the ocean waters began to
rage and froth, spraying foam and surf into
the air.
SCP-3700-2 burst from beneath the surface,
its head pointed upward.
It continued to rise until the tops of its
tentacles could be seen above the water, then
stopped to bend its torso and turn its head
horizontally.
Its jaw unhinged, exposing rows upon rows
of serrated teeth.
The beast let loose a mighty roar, accompanied
by a stream of blue flame.
At the sight of its rival, SCP-3700-1 dove
beneath the surface, disappearing from view.
The SCPS Mither ordered the rest of the vessels
to engage "Protocol Winter Maelstrom."
Delta-7 scattered out from SCP-3700-1's point
of submersion, and all thirteen destroyers
fired their harpoons at SCP-3700-2, embedding
themselves in the entity's head.
Naturally, this enraged the creature, and
it began to roar and wail, spinning its lower
body vigorously enough to generate a whirlpool.
The cruisers opened fire with a combination
of L-cannons and conventional weaponry in
order to distract the entity as the destroyers
pulled their harpoon lines taut, dragging
its head in a continuous circle.
While this was taking place, the battleships
got into position and prepared to fire on
the Mither's mark.
3...2...1...
FIRE!
The first broadside barrage collided with
SCP-3700-2, and it grunted in pain, thrashing
back and forth, before opening its mouth and
spewing an instance of SCP-3456 into the water.
As soon as it hit the water, the equine monster
began to cut through the water at a pace of
50 km/hour, making its way toward the destroyers,
particularly the SCPS Selkie.
The Selkie attempted to retarget its weapons
and prevent the creature from reaching it,
but the monster moved too quickly for the
Selkie to adjust.
The Selkie was lifted out of the water by
the creature as crew members desperately clung
to the railing and their weaponry.
As the crew cowered and tried to fend off
the creature, it reached for them, trying
to pull them from the ship.
While the Selkie was occupied, SCP-3700-2
was able to attack again, blasting another
ship with a stream of blue fire.
A loud CRACK rang out across the sea as the
Selkie dropped back into the water, the SCP-3456
instance shrieking in pain.
SCP-3700-1 burst through the surface of the
water, striking the creature with its club-like
limbs, each blow emitting another loud crack.
The third blow tore the instance in half,
sending its human torso careening through
the air and past the SCPS Mither.
Freed from its attack, the Selkie moved full
steam ahead, pulling the harpoon line tight
again and dragging SCP-3700-2 out of its path.
Several Selkie crew members were thrown overboard
during the struggle, and as they struggled
to keep their heads above water, SCP-3700-1
scooped them from the water, placing them
onto the deck of a nearby destroyer and out
of harm's way.
With the crew members rescued, SC-3700-1 set
its sights on its enemy, swimming toward the
edge of the whirlpool and emitting a luminescent
glow from two of its eyes.
The constant barrage of cannon fire on SCP-3700-2
was beginning to take its toll, and the Mither
ordered the fleet to "Brace for the killing
blow!"
As if responding to the Mither's call, SCP-3700-1
shot several concentrated blasts of gamma
radiation at its foe, leaving large holes
in the creature in their wake.
SCP-3700-2 screamed, flailing so hard that
it snapped the harpoon lines and created waves
large enough to push the vessels backward.
With this newfound freedom, SCP-3700-2 impaled
SCP-3700-1 through the midsection with the
barbed tip of its tail, lifting it up and
out of the water with the force of the blow.
SCP-3700-1 desperately tried to free itself,
attacking the tail with its club-like limbs,
but the fight was in vain, and after a moment,
all movement stopped.
SCP-3700-1 was, for at least the duration
of this manifestation, dead.
SCP-3700-2 tossed the corpse into the wair,
flinging it past Delta-7 where it crashed
into the water and sank down into the depths
below.
At this point, Delta-7 was ordered to initiate
Protocol Tumult.
The Delta-7 vessels turned away from SCP-3700-2,
preparing to evacuate the area.
One of the ships, the SCPS Stronsay Beast,
slowed behind the rest of the fleet, emitting
concerning amounts of smoke, before coming
to a stop.
Meanwhile, the enraged and emboldened SCP-3700-2
expanded the size of its whirlpool, setting
its sights on the retreating ships and the
weakened Stronsay Beast.
The ship tried to flee, but the engines were
completely shot and would not respond.
The ship was caught in the whirlpool and pulled
against its will toward SCP-3700-2.
As the crew looked on in helpless dread, a
tentacle rose from the deep, wrapping around
the vessel and dragging it toward the entity's
gaping maw.
Suddenly, SCP-3700-1 exploded from beneath
the surface of the water, leaping between
the ship and SCP-3700-2, cutting the tentacle
in half and freeing the Stronsay Beast from
its grip.
SCP-3700-2 shrieked, before closing its jaws
and biting down on SCP-3700-1.
It retaliated, emitting bright flashes of
light and doing enough damage to stop SCP-3700-2
from continuing to produce its whirlpool.
Another tentacle emerged from the water, pulling
at SCP-3700-1's legs and ripping them from
its body, but SCP-3700-1 returned the assault
in kind, bludgeoning SCP-3700-2 with its club-like
limbs from inside of its mouth.
All at once, SCP-3700-2's lower jaw was torn
out of place, dropping into the water with
SCP-3700-1 still inside.
SCP-3700-2 thrashed futilely, growing steadily
weaker and weaker.
It released one more stream of fire, before
collapsing.
Delta-7 paused their retreat, watching the
scene for any sign of a winner, but after
five minutes, neither entity had moved.
Delta-7 returned to the site of the battle
to investigate, and saw that neither entity
was moving, and both appeared to be deceased.
Shortly after Delta-7 reached the area, both
entities disappeared, leaving a single round
unidentified object that sank below the surface
where SCP-3700-1 had just been.
The wall clouds overhead dispersed, leaving
standard cumulonimbus clouds in their place.
The waters themselves remained choppy.
Unsure of how to proceed, the SCPS Mither
sent a radio transmission to Command.
"This is Delta-7 to Command."
"We read you Delta-7."
Command replied.
"We have a bit of a situation."
"Go ahead, Delta-7."
"SCP-3700-1 and 2 are both down."
Command was silent for ten seconds, utterly
baffled by the information.
"Please repeat Delta-7."
Again, the Mither said, "SCP-3700-1 and 2
are both down."
Command ordered the Mither to "stand by."
Three minutes of radio silence later, communication
resumed as they asked: "Are either entities'
effects active?"
"Negative command."
"Is there any trace of either entity?"
"Also negative."
"It appears the anomaly has been neutralized.
Dela-7 is to return to base for debrief following
any recovery efforts."
With their next steps clear, Delta-7 attached
the Stronsay Beast to several tug boats, preparing
to pull the vessel to safety.
But there were more surprises waiting.
The SCPS Mither began picking up unusual levels
of gamma radiation, as well as a sonar contact
at a depth of 3 km.
They called command, requesting permission
to deploy submersibles for exploration purposes.
One minute of silence followed, as the command
arrived at a decision.
"Request denied.
Return to base for debriefing."
And so, Delta-7 began to evacuate the area
once more, steaming in the opposite direction
of the battle.
Over the next five minutes, CCTV cameras on
the vessels picked up an unusual sight.
As the gamma radiation levels continued to
increase, the ocean turbulence also worsened,
tossing smaller vessels and nearly causing
them to capsize.
Then, all of a sudden, the waters stilled,
and four large, yellow orbs appeared below
the surface, approximately 300m from Delta-7.
They lingered there for two minutes before
vanishing.
Afterward, a new sonar contact was detected,
5k km deep, directly beneath the task force.
"Command, we've lost the signal from the previous
contact and are no longer detecting gamma
radiation.
We're detecting a new contact, 5 km deep,
large, and metallic."
After further deliberation, Command responded:
"Delta-7, you are authorized to deploy submersibles
for exploration purposes.
Be advised, should SCP-3700-2 manifest, exploration
teams are to be considered lost, and you are
to return to base."
The consequences of this incident, as well
as what else might be lurking down in the
depths beneath SCP-3700, are still unknown.
Now go check out “SCP-169 - Leviathan”
and “SCP-057-IT - Under the Sea!”